the second half of the season this is as
doc rivers said a full-on sprint as we
take a look at our kia what to watch
keys to tonight's game well this is one
of the teams the timberwolves that
crashes the boards you got to make sure
that you control the boards limit them
to one shot and then defend the threes
this is a team prolific in their
three-point attempts make sure that you
get them off the line make them shoot
some two
these two as i'm sure most of you sixers
fans remember matthew joelle's return
from his covet absence saturday november
27th went to double overtime with the
timberwolves taking that one 121
to 120 but of course sixers did not have
this man in the lineup that night
james harden
traded from brooklyn to philly
just about an hour before the trade
deadline was finished
on that thursday afternoon
sixers on a 6-0 run
edward's guardian harding james harden
driving and finishing
and so it begins the hardened arrow with
the sixers watch this watch the little
cross over here as he gets
right past edwards
right to the basket strong enough to
pick
fight through that contest
[Applause]
this is how the wolves are hoping to get
edwards back into a rhythm get him just
in motion on the drive reeve no good
from three here comes harden good pass
to tyrese maxie for two yeah i think
both guys are willing
worried about the drive so you play off
a little bit he takes advantage of that
space
[Music]
oh yeah
it's beverly i believe no beverly it was
russell
russell stunts but harden
from inside the arc and beyond a little
bit high mid 30s wow
49 is what the timberwolves are shooting
joelle count it
and he'll head to the line
final 90 seconds second quarter
thankfully no whistle on that out of
control shot from russell nibble leaking
out and slamming it home
[Applause]
happened so far sixers up ten hardened
step back and the foul
[Applause]
the first of many
in red white and blue
just trying to get a hand up
off balance picks up the contacts
[Applause]
yes sir oh baby
tell you it is comforting to have it
being done on your behalf as opposed to
being done to you on a nightly basis oh
whether he was
says let's slow things down for a minute
get the shot they want
step back
four-point opportunity
for james harden
here i am take a look at that step back
over the much taller
carl anthony town
msg take on the knicks on sunday oh
mama
james harden make it 27.